allowed to come home that night because
of another circumstance while I was in a
relationship I had a friend he was a
male friend
he offered to let me stay at his dinner
for the night it was very circumstantial
I know that from wherever we were so I
stayed at his and yes I slept in his bed
because I was not sleeping on the floor
in his house I just refused nothing had
couch
his mom's bed I said to him I would
rather sleep in your bed because I know
you and you can sleep in your mom's bed
so your boyfriend knew you had the
option of sleeping in his bed or his
mom's bed and you told him that yeah
we both we topped and tailed it so you
had options
I'll be honest with you yeah it would
have been it would have made more sense
for him to sleep in his mama's bed
because I can go to sleep
you should have gone I'm not sleeping in
your mom
this is the red flag okay
I'm just gonna just to clarify okay just
just here
I don't know but I'm just saying at the
time 100 questions
as loud as it as bad as it means this is
you
know
at the time bear in mind that this was a
lot of years ago yeah but at the time I
was so in love with my boyfriend that
the concept of this person who's
offering me a place to stay in his house
him even like having a but he's not
intention yes but in my head and my
heart I was so in love with who I was
with at the time if your boyfriend did
that to you would you be fine with that
if he called you and said listen I'm
gonna sleep with this some girl in her
bed don't worry about me but I'm not
gonna lie of course not but the
difference between me and him is that I
would voice that he
yeah but not old enough to understand
that
you see me just me but there's Babies
you understand what I'm saying that's
the next situation it's not an excuse
because that sounded much look no I know
it's already I'm gonna just put this out
there to any girls that are watching if
you're ever in this scenario do not stay
stay alive I wouldn't do it now I
wouldn't do it why wouldn't you do it
now because I understand boundaries
but as a child or as a late teacher
if someone kills someone at 18 are they
responsible
of course they can't say I'm a child no
but it's different because it's
circumstantial it wasn't like it went
like he was just oh yeah like you know I
got a free yard why don't you come over
and stayed I had nowhere to go do you
know what I'm saying
no okay do you know what I'm saying I
couldn't go to his it was just in the
time it was the only place that I felt
like I had to go and I remember even
talking to you at the time
do you get what I'm saying and it was
just at the time I was explaining that
and I'm not gonna lie of course I knew
how mad it looked but I explained to the
boy and you know we had our conversation
and even for me at the time I thought
the fact that we're even having this
conversation he already knew how in love
with my boyfriend I was it was just
circumstantial things can happen but
nothing happened
you said yeah it comes with maturity as
well you wasn't experience at this age
at this age I can I can give you the
side eye a bit but at 17 18. exactly
yeah
I think I think if you respect your man
that much you know the boundaries before
he even has to later 15 years old you
won't just begin you've only just
started dating yeah and you know full
well that you know not to sleep in
another man's bed when you're in a
relationship she said they were friends
at the time was my one of my closest
friends at the time okay he might be he
might be but was he your type if he was
your type and you stepped in the beds
maybe something would have happened
honestly that doesn't even matter within
itself because he could have put in
yourself in a situation where I I
understand that's your friend but at the
same time was your friend right you
could have been overpowered by him him
at the same time and that your boyfriend
only has to take you at your words he
doesn't know that nothing happened for
facts because again that's true that's
that's very true like you are the
gateway to sex at the end of the day you
can say that nothing had happened
between you and this man but right okay
that's perfectly fine that you're saying
that but he only can take you out your
word and who is he then to tell you that
I don't accept that you did this
that's disrespectful how do you know the
other person your friend wasn't having
feelings no but for me even waiting he
was waiting they always are waiting
Spider-Man at the time even if he did or
didn't if even if he whizzle wasn't
plotting for me it didn't matter because
I wasn't in my that's what I'm saying
it's circumstantial because for me and
where my head and heart was at the time
I didn't like why why is there so many
excuses why don't you just say I did
some dumb [ __ ] because it was so good
we're like oh it's circumstances
but it's like it's like I was young I
did some dumb [ __ ] and it was like for
me it was talking such one also I'm not
gonna lie like at the time he was the
person that I was with at that time he
was the first and only person that I'd
ever been with do you understand that I
know the person
no experience with men he was the first
guy so to me I had yeah okay I was I was
I was a virgin most of college and I I
like I don't feel like you could that's
an excuse like you you just know not
just you know I'll give that to you guys
it's not an excuse and now today no I
wouldn't I would never do that to a
person I'm sleeping with and I wouldn't
accept it from a person I'm sleeping
with but I'm saying it was just in a
retaliation to when
if a girl goes into a man's bed if a
girl goes into a man's bed then
something is destined to happen and I'm
just saying that from my experience it
wasn't so you can't generalize every
single woman under that umbrella because
it's not the truth because for me when I
was in my Circumstance the person that I
was with I was so in love with when I
went into this person's bed my mind
wasn't even in that headspace I'm going
through my situation with my family I'm
not even thinking of anything like that
I'm just in this boy's bed I'm sitting
there I'm crying I'm just depressed but
I just have somewhere to sleep that
night I'm not thinking oh because I'm
going to your bed obviously you didn't
have to sleep in his bed though
I'm gonna say one more thing if you
really loved your boyfriend you could
have slept on the floor
so next next for everyone at home having
Instagram in a relationship let's say in
a marriage as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible